NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: So last
time, we finished
talking about trabecular bone.
And what I wanted to
talk about this week
was tissue
engineering scaffolds.
So the idea with
tissue engineering
is you want to be able to repair
damaged or diseased tissue.
And typically, that's done
by regenerating the tissue
in some way.
So in your body, many types
of cells, like maybe not blood
cells, but most types of cells
for sort of structural tissues
are attached to an
extracellular matrix.
And this is sort of a schematic
of the extracellular matrix
here.
And the composition depends
on the type of tissue
that's involved.
For example, in skin, it would
be collagen and something
called glycosaminoglycans
and elastin.
In bone, it would be collagen
and a mineral-- a calcium
phosphate mineral,
hydroxyapatite.
So the composition varies.
But the idea with the
tissue engineering scaffold
is that you want to make a
material that essentially
substitutes for the
extracellular matrix.
And it does so on a
sort of temporary basis.
So the idea is you put
something in the body.
The cells attach to that,
whatever scaffold you put in.
And the scaffold has to
be made in such a way
that the material--
that the cells, they
can migrate through it.
They can attach to it.
They can differentiate.
They can proliferate.
So the cells can do all
their normal function.
And the idea is that
as the cells are
doing their normal
function, they then
secrete the natural
extracellular matrix.
And the engineered thing
that you put in is resorbed.
So there has to be a balance
between the rate at which
the scaffold you've made resorbs
and the rate at which the cells
are depositing the new
native extracellular matrix.
So that's one of the
key things about this.
So this is just an example
of sort of a schematic
of an extracellular matrix.
In this case here,
there's collagen fibers.
So these guys here
collagen fibers.
And these kind of hairy-looking
things are proteoglycans.
So they have a core of
protein with sugars kind
of hanging off of them.
And there's different kinds
of GAGs, they're called,
that hang off of them.
So one's chondroitin sulfate.
The CS here stands for
Chondroitin Sulfate.
There's one called
dermatan sulfate.
And there's one called
heparin sulfate.
So there's different of
these glycosaminoglycans.
So let me write
down some of this,
and then we'll kind
of get into this.
So what I wanted to
do today was show
you some examples of tissue
engineering scaffolds.
Show you some of the sort
of design requirements.
So you have to have, obviously,
a material that's porous
so the cells can get in there.
And that's where the
cellular solids comes in.
So we'll talk about
some scaffolds,
some of the sort of design
requirements for them.
And also, we'll
talk a little bit
about processing
of the scaffolds
and mechanical properties
of the scaffolds.
So I'm hoping I can
finish most of that today.
And then next time, I
have a little case study
on osteochondral scaffolds.
So osteo means bone.
And the chondral
means cartilage.
So this was sort of
a two-layer scaffold
that we developed
in collaboration
with some other people at MIT
and some people at Cambridge
University.
And it went from a research
thing to a startup thing
and being used clinically.
So I was going to talk
about that Wednesday.
OK.
So let me just get started here.
So the goal of
tissue engineering
is to regenerate diseased
or damaged tissues.
And in the body,
the cells attach
to the extracellular matrix.
And that's sometimes
called the ECM.
Sometimes, the scaffolds
are called scaffolds.
And sometimes,
they're called matrix
because the extracellular
matrix is called matrix.
So then, the composition of
the ECM depends on the tissue,
but it usually involves some
sort of structural protein.
So something like
collagen or elastin.
It also typically involves
some sort adhesive proteins.
So something like
fibronectin or laminin.
And it involves
these proteoglycans,
which are the core of protein
with a sugar hanging off them.
Whoops.
And the sugars are typically
glycosaminoglycans.
And for short, people call them
GAGs, just because it's easier
to say.
So some examples of the GAGs
are chondroitin sulfate.
And we're going to talk more
about that a little later
because that's one
that we've used
in making collagen-based
scaffolds with [INAUDIBLE].
So for example, if you
look at the composition
of extracellular matrix in
something like cartilage,
it has a collagen component
and a hyaluronic acid component
and some GAGs.
And this hyaluronic
acid is a proteoglycan.
If you look at bone,
extracellular matrix in bone,
it's made up mostly of
collagen and hydroxyapatite.
And if you look at skin, skin
is made up of collagen, elastin,
and proteoglycans.
And the idea is
that the cells have
to be attached to this
extracellular matrix
in order to function.
Or, they have to be attached to
this or to other cells in most
cases.
So next week, I'm going to talk
a bit about cell mechanics.
And we have some
video where we watch
a cell deforming a scaffold.
And I don't have
videos to show you,
but I had a student who took
videos of cells migrating along
with scaffolds.
We'll look at how the
stiffness of the scaffold
affects how the cells
migrate along the scaffold.
So that's kind of the
native ECM in the body.
And the idea with
tissue engineering
is that you want to
make a scaffold that's
porous that mimics
the extracellular
matrix in the body.
So, say, there's some
tissue that's damaged.
Say there's damaged cartilage.
You want to provide sort
of an extracellular matrix
that's a sort of
synthetic thing that's
going to provide the
same function as the ECM
in the native tissue.
So people have been working
on scaffolds for regenerating
all sorts of different tissues.
And probably, the
most successful one
has been used to
regenerate skin.
And there's been
scaffolds available
for regenerating skin for
probably almost 20 years now.
And one of the first
ones was developed
by Professor Yannas in
mechanical engineering
here at MIT.
And it's actually still sold
by a company called Integra.
But this research
to develop scaffolds
for lots of different tissues,
orthopedic tissues, things
like bone and cartilage,
cardiovascular tissues,
nerve-- like Professor Yannas
works on peripheral nerve
these days.
People have looked at
trying to make scaffolds
for gastrointestinal tissues.
So all sorts of
different tissues.
And at MIT, there's quite
a lot of interest in this.
There's a lot of
people working on it.
So Bob Langer works on it.
Linda Griffith.
Sangeeta Bhatia.
There's really quite a number
of people at MIT who work on it.
Those are just some
of the people at MIT.
So the idea is in
the body, the cells
are constantly resorbing
the extracellular matrix
and depositing more.
So if you think about
bone, for example.
Remember we said bone
grows in response to load?
Even in healthy bone, the bone
is constantly being resorbed
and deposited.
And in normal bone,
the rate of resorption
and the rate of deposition
is roughly the same.
When people get osteoporosis,
the thing that happens
is that that balance
gets out of whack.
And so it's not being
deposited at the same rate
it's being resorbed.
And the idea with the
tissue engineering scaffolds
is that they degrade over time.
And that the cells that
were attached to them
are forming their own
extracellular matrix.
So there's kind
of a balancing act
between the cells
depositing the native ECM
and the tissue
engineering scaffold that
was provided, say, by the
clinician being resorbed.
So the scaffolds are
actually designed to degrade.
And controlling that
degradation rate
is one of the design
parameters of the scaffolds.
OK.
So that's kind of the
overall, kind of big picture.
And what I wanted
to talk about next
was some design requirements
for the scaffolds.
So if you think
about it, there's
different sort of ways
you can think about what
the requirements are.
So you have to make the
scaffold out of some solid.
And there's some
requirements for the solid.
So obviously, you want a
solid that's biocompatible.
That's one kind of
main requirement.
Another requirement is
that not only the solid has
to be biocompatible, but
when the solid decomposes,
if it decomposes into
other components,
they have to be
biocompatible too.
So you don't want the solid to
degrade during this resorption
process into toxic components.
That would be a bad idea.
And then, the other
thing is the solid
itself has to promote
cell attachment, and cell
proliferation, and
cell migration, all
these kinds of things.
So we're going to talk about
some different materials
for the scaffolds.
And some of them are
sort of native proteins.
So some of them are things
like collagen. Collagen already
has binding sites for
cells to attach to it.
Obviously, it's one of the
proteins in the native ECM.
There's also a number of
synthetic polymers you can use.
And with the synthetic
polymers, they
don't have natural binding
sites for the cells.
And so you have to coat
them with something else.
So you have to coat them with,
say, adhesive proteins so
that the cells will
attach to them.
So we're going to talk about
the requirements for the solid.
Then, you make the
solid into some sort
of porous, foamy thing.
I think I have some slides here.
Here's an example of a
collagen GAG scaffold.
And this is one of the ones
that is made in Yannas' lab.
And you can see it
looks a lot like a foam.
It's very, very porous.
And there's some
requirements for the sort
of cellular structure, the
foamy structure of the scaffold
as well.
So typically, you want
interconnected pores
so it's easy for the
cells to migrate in.
Typically, you want pores to
be within a certain range.
It turns out if the
pores are too small,
it makes it difficult
for the cells to get in.
Sometimes, they can by
eating away at the material.
But typically, the pores--
you want them to be bigger
than a certain size.
You also want them to be
smaller than a certain size
because how much specific
surface area, how much surface
area per unit volume you've
got, depends on the pore size.
The smaller the pores,
the more surface area
per unit volume you have.
And then, the number
of binding sites
you have for cells
to attach to it
depends on that
specific surface area.
I'm going to write all
this down, so I'll do that.
So there's requirements for
sort of the pore structure.
And then, there's
also some requirements
for the whole scaffold itself.
So for instance,
it's got to have
some minimal
mechanical integrity.
So there's sort of some
requirements for that.
So there's requirements
for the solid.
There's requirements for the
sort of cellular structure,
the porous structure.
And there's requirements
for the overall scaffold.
So let me write some
of these things down.
So there's some
requirements for the solid.
So it must be biocompatible.
It must also promote cell
attachment and proliferation
in the cell functions.
And then it must degrade
into nontoxic components.
So there's some requirements
for the cellular structure, too.
And what you want to have
is a large volume fraction
of interconnected pores.
And so you want that to
facilitate the cell migration.
And also, the transport of
nutrients into the cells.
So you also want the pore size
to be within a critical range.
So you need the pores
bigger than a lower
limit so the cells can
migrate through easily,
can kind of get in there.
And you want the pore size to
be less than an upper limit
to have enough surface area
to have enough binding sites
to actually attach cells.
And for different
tissues, there's
different critical
ranges of the pore size.
So for example,
for skin they found
that you want to have a pore
size between about 20 microns
and about 150 microns.
And for bone, the pore sizes
that people tend to use
are between about
100 and 500 microns.
So there's the pore size.
And one other feature is
that the pore geometry should
be conducive for the cell type.
So lots of cells are
somewhat equiaxed.
Maybe a little elongated.
But if you look at
something like nerve cells,
like peripheral nerve,
they're incredibly elongated.
So you want to have pores
in the scaffold that
are also very elongated.
And then for the
overall scaffold,
it needs to have some
mechanical integrity.
You guys OK?
Yeah?
We're good.
Oh, achy.
Yeah.
I know.
So you want to have some
overall mechanical integrity.
I mean, the thing has to be
put into the body in surgery.
And people are going to be
pushing and poking at it.
And so it has to have some just
overall mechanical integrity.
Also, it turns out that if you
put stem cells into scaffolds,
the types of cells
they differentiate into
depends in part on the
stiffness of the scaffold.
So you want to be
able to control
the stiffness of the scaffold.
AUDIENCE: How do they
do this research?
Do they use animals?
Or they do it in vitro?
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah.
So the question is, how
do they do the research?
So they do a sort of
series of different things.
So at one level, you
could have the scaffold
and you'd put cells on it.
Say you're making
a bone scaffold.
You'd put osteocytes onto it.
So one level, you just
put cells onto it.
And you want to see,
are the cells attaching?
Are they dying?
Are they proliferating?
So sometimes, what
people will do
is put the-- they'll seed
a certain number of cells
at a certain time.
Say, time 0.
Then, they'll look at how
many cells are attached
at 24 hours or 48 hours.
And you kind of see
the cell attachment.
You can measure
relatively easily.
Another thing people
do is animal studies.
So for instance,
Yannas does research
on peripheral
nerves and scaffolds
for peripheral nerves.
And they cut a piece out of
the sciatic nerve of rats.
So obviously, they
have a surgeon
and do a surgery thing with it.
You can't just kind
of do this in the lab.
You've got to get permissions
and stuff to do it.
And then, they put
in the scaffold.
And the scaffold's
actually in a tube.
And so they put the two
stumps of the nerve end
at either end of the
tube, and then the tube's
filled with a sort
of porous scaffold
that we're talking about here.
And then, they wait
some period of time.
And they take video of rat
running, things like that.
They then sacrifice the
rat and they do histology.
And they look at the
sort of cross-sections
and see what it looks like.
And so I'm going
to talk next time
about this osteochondral
scaffold we worked on.
So we did cell studies.
We did goat studies.
We put into goat knees.
There was a longer
term sheep study.
And then, the student who's
in Cambridge, England,
started up a company
and he ended up
getting approval in Europe
to start clinical trials.
And then he worked with
an orthopedic surgeon who
started putting it in people.
But typically, they're looking
at cells, looking at animals
before you get to
the people stage.
And one of the
things people do when
they're making
these scaffolds is
you want to use
materials that already
have some sort of
regulatory approval.
So say FDA approval
or approval in Europe.
So typically, people don't
start with a brand new material
from scratch.
Because to get approval
for that would just
take a very long time.
So typically, people start
with-- the solid material
is already approved for
some other sort of use.
OK.
So one requirement for
the overall scaffold
is it has to have sufficient
mechanical integrity.
Sufficient.
And then also, as I mentioned,
the stiffness of the scaffold
can affect
differentiation of cells.
And the other thing
that is really
a factor for the
overall scaffold
is you want to control
the rate of degradation
of the overall scaffold.
So you want that
rate to be matched
to the rate at which the
new tissue is forming.
So it has to degrade
at a controllable rate.
OK.
So I want to talk about the
materials that people use.
And you can kind of break
them down into a few classes.
So one class is
natural polymers.
So things like collage.
So you can get collagen.
And that's an example up
there of a scaffold
that's made with collagen.
Another class of materials
is synthetic biomaterials.
And if you've had
stitches or surgery,
you may know that some
of the sutures they use
are resorbable.
So some of those
polymers that they
use for resorbable sutures
are also used for tissue
engineering scaffold.
And then, there's also hydrogels
that people use as well.
So those are probably
the three main groups
are sort of natural polymers,
synthetic biopolymers,
and I guess the
hydrogels are sort
of a subset of the
sympathetic biopolymers.
So collagen is probably the most
common kind of natural polymer
that's used.
They also use GAGs.
And this scaffold
up here is made
by making a coprecipitative
collagen with a GAG chondroitin
sulfate.
People also use alginate.
I think one of the
project groups--
you guys are going to make
some sort of alginate scaffold,
right?
No?
[INAUDIBLE] foamy thing?
Yeah.
And people also use
something called chitosan,
which is a derivative
of chiton, which
is what's in the exoskeleton
of insects and things
like lobsters.
So those would be all
examples of natural polymers
that can be used and
people have tried.
I'm going to talk a bit
more about collagen,
just because it's
the most common one.
So collagen is a major component
in the natural extracellular
matrix.
And not surprisingly, it
has binding sites for cells
to attach to it.
So if you use that, that kind
of takes care of that issue.
Let me put it down here.
So collagen exists in
many types of tissues.
Exists in skin.
Exists in bone, cartilage,
ligament, tendon-- cartilage.
So it's very common.
It has surface binding
sites for cells.
It has a relatively
low Young's modulus.
So the Young's modulus is a
little less than a gigapascal.
But you can increase the
modulus by either cross-linking
or by using it in conjunction
with some synthetic polymers.
And I'm going to talk a
little bit about how you
make these scaffolds up here.
And the first step in
making those scaffolds
is you put the collagen
in acetic acid,
and then you add the
glycosaminoglycan
and it forms a coprecipitate.
And the fact that it
forms a coprecipitate
with the
glycosaminoglycan, the GAG,
means that you can use
a freeze-drying process.
And that's how that's made.
Collagen is one option.
So then synthetic biopolymers
is another option.
And as I said, typically
they use the materials
that are used for
resorbable sutures.
So there's several of those.
There's something called PGA.
That's polyglycolic acid.
And something called PLA.
That's polylactic acid.
And then you can combine
those two and make something
called PLGA polylactic
co-glycolic acid.
And you can control
the degradation rate
of these things by controlling
the molecular weight.
And in this case, you
can also control it
by controlling how much of each
of those things you put in.
And there's another one
called polycaprolactone.
So those are several synthetic
biopolymers that people use.
There's lots of
different materials,
but these are just
some typical ones.
And then another
class are hydrogels,
which are produced by
cross-linking water
soluble polymers to form
an insoluble network.
And those are typically
used for soft tissues.
Sometimes, they're used
for things like cartilage.
And again, there's a
few different materials
that are commonly used.
One's PEG, Polyethylene Glycol.
One's PVA, Polyvinyl Alcohol.
And another one's
PAA, Polyacrylic Acid.
So for these synthetic
polymers, there's
many different processing
techniques available.
And I'll talk a
little bit about some
of the processing techniques.
But one of the
limitations is they don't
have natural binding sites.
And you have to coat them with
some sort of binding agent,
like an adhesive protein, to
get the cells to attach to them.
And then, as I mentioned
before, you have to make sure
that whatever
material you choose,
if it's a synthetic material
that when it degrades,
it's not toxic to the cells.
Because you don't want to have
some sort of toxic reaction
or inflammation.
OK.
So there's a couple more
things about materials.
So those are all
polymer-based materials.
When people are trying to
make scaffolds for bone tissue
engineering, they also include
a calcium phosphate mineral.
And there's different versions
of the calcium phosphate.
So they can include-- you
can buy, for instance,
hydroxy powders now.
There's another
calcium phosphate
called octacalcium phosphate,
which will, with water, turn
into hydroxyapatite.
So typically, there is this
mineral, some sort of calcium
phosphate, is combined
with either collagen
or with one of these
synthetic biopolymers.
And one other
option is something
called an acellular scaffold.
And what that is they
take some natural tissue
and they remove all the
cell material from it.
And so when they remove all
the cell material, what they're
left with is the native ECM.
And that's called an
acellular scaffold.
So it's a native ECM with
all the cell matter removed.
And they remove
the cells by-- they
can use sort of a physical
agitation or chemical,
or using enzymatic methods.
Using something like trypsin
to get rid of the cell.
So there's ways that they
can get rid of the cells.
OK.
So are we good so far?
So there are some requirements
for what materials we
kind of use, what the
cell structure should be,
and these are some examples
of typical materials.
So I wanted to talk a little
bit about the processing
of the materials.
Let me wait until people
catch up a little.
Oh, and I have some scaffolds
I was going to pass around.
So this big sheet is a piece
of the collagen GAG scaffold
that I showed a minute ago.
And then this little piece is
a mineralized version of that.
So this has the collagen
plus calcium phosphate
plus hydroxyapatite in it.
OK.
So this slide shows some
examples of different scaffolds
that people have made.
And I was going to
talk a little bit
about some of these methods.
And why don't I talk
about them, and then I'll
write some notes on the board.
So this top one here on the top
left, that's the collagen GAG
scaffold that's made
in Yannas' group.
And that's made by a
freeze-drying process.
So you put the collagen
in acetic acid,
then you put in the GAG.
The GAG and the collagen
form a coprecipitate.
And then you can freeze that.
And if you freeze
it, what happens
is-- it's just like if
you freeze saltwater.
The water freezes.
The pure water freezes.
And you've got increasingly
higher brine content
in the bit in between the water
grains, or in between the ice.
So you get the sort
of solid ice forming.
And the collagen and
the GAG are kind of
squeezed into the interstitial
bits between the ice crystals.
And then if you
sublimate the ice off,
you're left with this
porous kind of structure
that looks like a foam.
So that's made by a
freeze-drying process.
And I'll go over it in
a bit more detail when
I write the notes on the board.
You could also foam
some of these polymers.
So just blowing a gas.
The same way you can blow a
gas through engineering foam.
You do the same thing with
some of these polymers.
This one's made by foaming.
You can have a
fugitive phase process.
So this is made by salt
leaching, the second row
on the left there.
So you could imagine you
could take a polymer powder.
You could mix it with
salt. You can sort of
mix them up, combine
them together.
You heat it up to get the
polymer to melt and to sort
of form a connected mass.
And then you leech
out the salt. And then
you get pores
where the salt was.
This one here is made by
an electrospinning process.
So you have a nozzle.
You feed the polymer
through the nozzle.
Then you have plates
that are charged
and you get fibers forming
and kind of scattered
in different directions by
the electrospinning process.
Then, this one here
represents scaffolds
that are made by things like
3D printing, selective laser
centering.
You can have
laser-sensitive polymer.
And you can produce
scaffolds that way.
I think the geometry of this one
matches some part in the body.
I think it was a knee
or something like that.
And then, these two
examples down here
are the acellular scaffolds.
That's what I was talking
about at the very end there.
So those are from porcine
pork heart tissue.
You know, pig heart tissue.
And those are mostly elastin.
And they've had all the cell
matter removed from them.
OK.
So you can kind of see that
these synthetic scaffolds here
have a structure that's not so
different from these native ECM
scaffolds down here.
OK.
So let me write some of the
things about the processing
on the board.
Let me rub this off.
Start over here.
So these freeze-dried scaffolds
are used for skin regeneration.
And I think I have
some more slides here.
So it's kind of a
two-step process.
In the first step, you make
what they call a slurry.
So you make the slurry
by taking the collagen.
And for skin, I think you want
type 1 collagen. Yeah, skin
is type 1 collagen.
There's different types.
You put it in acetic acid,
and then you add the GAG.
And we use chondroitin 6-sulfate
is just the particular GAG
that we use.
And one of the things
that the acid does
is that it swells the
collagen. And collagen
has a sort of periodic
structure in it,
sort of periodic banding.
And the acid destroys that
periodic banding structure.
And that helps
increase the resistance
to having some host
immune response.
So that you remove the
immunological markers
and it makes it less likely
that the scaffold's going
to get rejected by the body.
So then when you put the GAG
in, you form a coprecipitate.
So this next step
just shows kind
of mixing the whole thing up.
And then you've got
kind of a little slurry
that you can store.
And then, this is the
freeze-drying step here.
So you put the slurry, the
suspension, into a pan.
Kind of just like a
cookie sheet, really.
And then you freeze it.
So if you think of
this phase diagram
here, where you have
temperature and pressure.
So here we have liquid,
solid, and vapor.
So if you start off at this
point here, you freeze it.
So you've reduced
the temperature.
So that forms the ice.
And the ice is surrounded by
the collagen and the GAG fibers.
And then if you do
the sublimation step,
you reduce the pressure and
increase the temperature a bit.
And then you get over to
the vapor end of the world.
And then you're left with
this porous scaffold.
And then, let me see.
Let me do one more step here.
And then you can control
the size of the pores
by controlling the
freezing temperature.
So the size of the
pores is exactly
related to the size of the
ice grains that are forming.
And the faster it freezes,
the smaller the grains
are going to be.
And then, the smaller your
pore size are going to be.
So you can control that.
The type 1 collagen is
mixed with acetic acid.
And it then swells the collagen
and disrupts periodic banding.
And it removes
immunological markers.
And then you add the GAG,
the chondroitin 6-sulfate.
And then that cross
links with the collagen
and forms a coprecipitate.
And then you can freeze dry
that to get the porous scaffold.
And typically, the relative
densities of these scaffolds
is very low.
So typically,
they're 0.5% dense.
The relative density is 0.005.
So they're 99.5% air
and the rest of it's
the collagen and the GAG.
And the pore sizes are typically
between about 100 and 150
microns.
And Yannas uses
the same scaffolds
for the nerve regeneration.
And he uses a
directional cooling.
And that then
elongates the pores,
so that-- the idea is that they
elongate so the nerves kind
of grow along that length.
So that's one way.
Another way is leaching
a fugitive phase.
So let's see.
I think-- yep.
Here we go.
Back to there.
So if you look at the one on
the second row on the left,
that's done by using salt
as the fugitive phase.
People use other things.
You can use wax.
Paraffin wax works as well.
So it doesn't have
to be salt. There's
different things you can use.
So you combine a
powder of the polymer
with your fugitive
phase Say, salt.
Then, you heat it up to
get the polymer to bind.
And then you leach out the salt.
So you can control the porosity
by the volume fraction
of the fugitive phase,
and then the pore size
by the size of whatever
the fugitive phase is.
Another technique
is electrospinning.
The idea is you produce
fibers from a polymer solution
that you extrude
through a nozzle.
And then you apply a
voltage across some plates
to spin the fibers.
And then you get a
network of these fibers.
And typically, their
micron-scale diameter.
And the last method
I'm going to talk about
is rapid prototyping.
So you can think of
using 3D printing.
Or you could use selective laser
centering or stereo lithography
using a photo-sensitive polymer.
So the idea is-- you
know how this works.
You just build up layers of
solid, one layer at a time.
And then you can make
complex geometries with that.
So that's one of the advantages.
If you wanted to make a part
to fit a particular place
in the tissue, then
it's convenient
that you can control the
geometry of the whole part.
OK.
So that just kind of
summarizes very briefly,
kind of how the tissue
engineering scaffolds
are meant to work, what
kinds of materials people
make them from, and a
few of the processes.
And there's many,
many processes.
These are just sort of
a few common processes.
I wanted to talk a little bit
about the mechanical behavior
because that's
kind of what I do.
And so this next plot just
shows a stress strain curve
in compression for a
collagen GAG scaffold.
And I'm hoping
that by now you're
getting the idea all of
these cellular materials
have this kind of
shape of a curve.
So there's the same kind of
linear elastic regime, and then
a collapse plateau.
These collagen things,
as you can imagine just
pressing them in
your hand, they fail
by buckling, by
inelastic buckling.
And then there's a
densification regime.
So they look like all the other
kinds of curves that we've got.
One of the things we've
done in the modeling
is typically in
the model, we want
to be able to
calculate or measure
the modulus of the solid or
the strength of the solid
from which the thing's made.
So [? Brendan ?] Harley
was one of my PhD students.
And he took a little
microscope, cut a little strut.
The struts are very small.
The pore size is 100 microns.
So the struts are on that order.
He glued one end of the
strut to a glass slide,
and then he used an AFM probe
to do a little bending test
on that little strut.
If he could measure the
deflection, he knew the length.
He knew the geometry
of the strut.
He could figure out what the
modulus was for the solid.
So he backs out
what the modulus is.
So he did these
measurements on a dry strut.
And then by comparing
the overall modulus
of a dry scaffold
with a wet scaffold,
he estimated what the
modulus of the wet scaffold
or the wet strut would be.
So the modulus of
the dry collagen GAG
was 672 megapascals.
A little less than a gigapascal.
And wet it was about 5.
So there's a huge difference
between the wet and the dry.
OK.
So let me just write a
few notes about that.
So in compression,
there's the three regimes
that we see for all
these cellular materials.
And so you can estimate the
modulus by using the model
we have for the foam
for the modulus.
The modulus of the foam divided
by the modulus of the solid
goes as the relative
density squared.
And that's related to
bending in the cell wall.
And then, the collapse plateau
is related to elastic buckling.
And so that's equal
to some constant times
E of the solid times the
relative density squared.
And that's related
to elastic buckling.
And then we measured E of the
solid doing this little AFM
beam bending test.
OK.
And for one of these
low-density scaffolds,
we measured the modulus.
We measured the
buckling strength.
And we got pretty good agreement
by using these equations here.
And the good agreement was
if this constant was 0.2.
That was the strain,
that buckling.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what does it
mean to be wet in here?
And why is it so much lower?
LORNA GIBSON: Well,
we make the scaffolds
by this freeze-drying thing.
And like this thing I
passed around, that was dry.
We just immerse it in water.
We just put it in water.
And then, he does the test.
So he does the test on
the whole scaffold dry,
and then he does the test
on the whole scaffold wet.
And I assume there's some sort
of bonding that gets disrupted
by having the water.
I don't know the details
of how that works,
but there must be some
change in the bonding
to make that happen.
So let's see.
I'm trying to see.
What else should we do today?
Oh, yeah.
So we get pretty good
agreement with this sort
of simple foamy model.
One of the things
we did find was
that when we tested
higher-density scaffolds,
the agreement wasn't so good.
And I think this was because
when you get higher density,
it's just hard to get the
collagen GAG mixture to mix in
with the acetic acid.
And so we ended up getting
inhomogeneous scaffolds
with sort of large
voids in them.
So in order for the
modeling to work,
you have to have a scaffold
that's relatively homogeneous.
You don't have kind
of big defects in it.
I think that's all I'm
going to say about that.
I have one more slide here.
So those are sort of
three-dimensional scaffolds
we've been talking about.
Sort of foam-like scaffolds.
People have also made
honeycomb-like scaffolds
as well.
And this just
shows some examples
of some honeycomb-type
scaffolds.
So this one here, I think was
made in Sangeeta Bhatia's lab.
You can sort of think
of it as a hexagon,
but it's also kind of
triangulated as well.
These two here were made
by George Engelmayr.
He worked with Bob
Langer at one point.
And these two
scaffolds here, they're
both sort of rectangular cells.
And they were designed
to look at how
the cell geometry
or the pore geometry
affected the sort of morphology
of the cells that attached.
So if you have different,
say, [? porous, ?]
you get different
morphology in the cells
that you're trying to attach.
And then, George Engelmayr
also made these scaffolds here.
And those were designed
to be anisotropic and have
different mechanical properties
in different directions.
And I think what
they had done was
try to match the anisotropy
in the mechanical properties
to anisotropy in heart
tissue, in cardiac tissue.
So these are some examples
of honeycomb-type scaffolds.
So let me just write down
a few things about those.
So I think these were
more-- obviously,
the scaffolds are
used-- the ultimate goal
is to use them clinically.
But sometimes, people
make scaffolds just
to study cell behavior.
And some of these, I
think, were made just
to study how the cells
would behave on them.
So they're sort of
idealized to do that.
So that triangulated.
It kind of looks like a
hexagon, but there's also
sort of triangles in there.
I think the thing
they were looking
at with that was transport
of nutrients to cells.
And from a mechanical point
of view, if it's triangulated
you'd expect, say, the
modulus of that to go linearly
with how much solid
there is there.
So the rectangular honeycomb
and the diamond shaped
pores, they were used to study
the effect of pore geometry
on the cell orientation.
They used fibroblasts.
And I'm going to call it the
accordion-like honeycomb.
That's mechanically anisotropic.
And the mechanical anisotropy is
matched to the cardiac tissue.
OK.
So I think I'm going to
stop there for today.
That's sort of the
end of this part.
And next time, I'm
going to talk about
the osteochondral scaffolds.
I don't think it really
makes sense to start it
for two or three minutes.
So I'll start that tomorrow.
Or Wednesday.
And we should be able to
finish that on Wednesday.
So one of the things that these
honeycomb-type scaffolds kind
of suggests is that
the scaffolds are
used both to try to
regenerate tissue
in the body in
clinical applications,
but they're also used as sort
of an environment for cells,
in order to study cell behavior.
So next time, I'm
going to talk about
an osteochondral scaffold.
And the idea with that was
to try to use it clinically.
But next week, I'm going to
talk about cell mechanics a bit.
And when people
study cell mechanics,
or look at the mechanics
of biological cells, not
the cellular structures.
So when people look at trying
to study how cells behave,
they need some environment
to put them on.
Typically, people started by
just using flat 2D substrates.
But the flat 2D substrates
are kind of easy to study,
but they don't really represent
the tissue in the body.
And so people are now using
tissue engineering scaffold
as an environment
that they can control
to study how cells behave.
So they study cell attachment,
cell proliferation,
cell migration, and
cell differentiation
all by using the
scaffolds as kind
of a controlled environment.
So we'll talk about
that, probably not--
I don't know if we'll
get to it on Wednesday.
But we might start
it on Wednesday
and finish it next week.
OK?